le bras de fer dure depuis plusieurs
jours alors qu astrazeneca annoncé
vendredi une baisse de 60% de ses
livraisons vers l'union européenne les
vingt-sept sommes désormais le
laboratoire de lui fournir comme convenu
les 80 millions de doses commandées
les 27 membres de l'union européenne
sont d'accord sur le fait qu'astra zykë
à doit respecter les livraisons stipulé
dans le contrat
le noeud du problème c'est bien ce
contrat encore confidentiel dans l'union
européenne la fabrication du vaccin est
assurée aux pays bas et en belgique
mais ces deux sites ont la productivité
la plus faible du réseau selon pascal
soriot pourtant l'union européenne la
sueur dans le contrat il est stipulé que
le laboratoire doit compenser le manque
de rendement de ses usines européennes
par des doses fabriquées au royaume uni
1.2 contre a démenti formellement dans
plusieurs journaux européens mardi par
le pdg d'astrazeneca
nous ne nous sommes aucunement engagée
auprès de lieux
on a dit on fera de notre mieux mais
sans garantie de réussir lieu voulait
plus ou moins autant de vaccins que le
royaume uni alors qu'il signait trois
mois après londres a stipulé que
l'approvisionnement provenant de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement britannique
irait d'abord au royaume uni il est
mentionné que les sites de fabrication
britannique était une option pour
l'europe mais seulement plus tard
problème les états membres ont dépensé
beaucoup 336 millions d'euros et sont
sous pression alors que d'autres
laboratoires comme pfizer ont également
réduit leur livraison en filigrane lui
accuse astrazeneca de favoriser la
production et la distribution de doses à
destination du royaume uni alors que les
dirigeants européens comptaient sur ces
doses moins chers et dont la
conservation est plus simple que celle
de ses concurrents le fait que
l'entreprise ne soit pas obligé de nous
livrer car nous aurions accepté qu'elle
fasse de son mieux
ce n'est ni correct ni acceptable
qu'elle ne soit pas capable d'assurer la
fabrication va à l'encontre de notre
accord
nous rejetons la loi du premier arrivé
premier servi
astrazeneca devait se justifier devant
la commission ce mercredi mais le
laboratoire anglo-suédois quittait la
réunion selon plusieurs dirigeants son
vaccin doit encore être homologué en
europe alors même que des doutes
subsistent quant à son efficacité sur
les populations âgées
cible principale des plans de
vaccination européen
de son côté pascal soriot assurée qu'à
partir de février 17 % de la capacité de
production de ses usines seraient
mobilisés pour l'europe